خرج منتخب مصر من كاس امم افريقيا من دوري
16 عندما خسر امام الكونغو الديمقراطيه
كيف خسر ومعه الفرعون المصري فخر العرب
لماذا يا صلاح نراك في ليفربول مثل النمر
لا احد يشم غبارك تهز الشباك الاعادي تسجل
الاهداف ومع منتخب مصر يفتر ادائك لحظه يا
جماعه ارحمونا صلاح كان مصابا اصيب عندما
لعب منتخب مصر مع غانا اصيب بشد عضلي في
فخذه ها هي الاصابه لكن جمهور كره القدم
لا يفهم بهذه السوالف طالما انت لاعب وانا
اشجعك سجل جول لشوف الان طيب معي شد عضلي
سجل والا بعد التسجيل نتفاهم بعد المباراه
استرجل يالا لم تسجل انت غير وطني لست
اهلا للقب عجوز خيبت امال الامه لست فخرا
للعرب لا تستحق المرتب العالي الذي تقبضه
ماذا يفعل الرجل بنفسه مع كل هذه
الضغوط لجا الى كتب التنميه البشريه التي
ترفع المزاج وترفع المعنويات وتساعد على
التطنيش نشر بعض النصائح التي اعجبته من
هذه الكتب على حسابه على انستغرام تقول
النصيحه كن نفسك ما تكونش زي ما حد عاوز
ما تسجن نفسك في اراء
الاخرين ما تفصل نفسك على مقاسي اي حد
اللي عاوز 47 واللي عاوز 39 واللي عاوز
42 ما تسمحش لاي حد
يشوفك او يشوف فيك نفسه ويحاول يحقق من
خلالك احلامه الشخصيه ما توافقش ان اي حد
يشوفك امتداد ليه او لمشروعه الاستثماري
الخاص اخر ما ورد في هذه الرسائل والنصائح
ما تسمحش لاي حد يقبلك بشروط او يحبك
بشروط او يحترمك بشروط انت نفسك وبس ما
تتحسب كده يا
صلاح كيف رايتم هذه الرساله كيف رايتم
نصائح التي يقراها صلاح اوهو مقتنع بها ام
لا جاسر يقول لك خلاص صلاح ما يهموش اي
مصري عربي وبال جزء هذا من الكتاب صلاح
الغرور عماه هو لا يعلم انه خلاص فن
وهو متوقع انه لسه في انجازات لا يا مستر
خلاص الكيرف في النزول والنزول السريع
كمان محمد سلامه قال يا ريتك ما تيجي
المنتخب تاني عندك كم سنه ولم تحصل على
بطوله من مع المنتخب عز الدين قال والله
على حق كل واحد يمثل نفسه فقط الثرثار من
يراقب الناس ويقارن تاج بعيدا عن وجع
العين اللي بيحصل لما الواحد يقرا كتاب
باللغه العاميه هو صلاح دراما كوين ولا
انا بيته لي يارا تقول يارا الواضح من هذه
الرساله ان محمد صلاح لو يعير اهتماما
لاراء الناس التي تشجعه وان كل ما يهمه هو
الاموال التي يجنيها من ليفربول فهي لا
تقارن بما يحصل عليه من المنتخب المصري
على كل حال اصابه محمد صلاح لم تؤثر فقط
على المنتخب المصري اثرت على ليفربول
يورجن كلوب يقول لك ان صلاح تغيب عن
مباراتين مع ريدز بسبب الاصابه وبالفعل
خسر امام امسي ليفربول امام ارسنال ثلاثه
مقابل واحد في الدوري الانجليزي الممتاز
انتم ما رايكم اكتبوه في التعليقات